the disappearance of 43 students over
two months ago in the southern state of
Guerrero it's an episode that has made
all of country all of Old Mexico
very sad we're deeply sad and deeply
worried it's been horrible horrible
disappearance we've been working from
the very beginning in making sure that
we find out what really happened to
these 43 students these students might
have disappeared because of the
collision at that level the municipality
level of the local government with the
organized crime this is of course
something terrible something that as I
said before women issue we've been
tackling from the very beginning and I
will take us many more months and years
but we're working hard on making sure
that Mexico is on the right path
called it gruesome and many are saying
why has this investigation taken so long
why do we still not know what happened
to the students and why has it taken
frankly so much to find out the truth it
was just that perhaps it hasn't been
done in the right way no it has been
done in the best possible way and the
best possible way is involving foreign
institutions like the inter-american
Court of Justice that has set out a
special commission to work along the
Mexican federal authorities in making
sure that we find out exactly what
happened
it has taken time because the necessary
investigations involve finding out
whether the human remains that were
found are or belong to some of the
missing students and that that doesn't
happen overnight but in the meantime
what's your message to those desperate
families of these missing students we've
talked to many of them and many of them
are suffering a terrible time obviously
not known what happened to their loved
ones and wanting answers and wanting
more faith in the state certainly and we
shared that worry was sure that sadness
we share that feeling that these
families have from the very beginning
there's been constant communication with
them the president himself sat down with
them few weeks back for a whole
afternoon over five hours of sitting
with the families getting to hear their
stories getting to listen what they have
to said getting to know what their
worries are so the communication is
constant and we want to stop that
channel of communication we want them to
have first-hand information now we've
had President Obama in the last 24 hours
expressing concern about the situation
in Mexico offering assistance saying
it's gruesome to see these kind of
events taking place in the first time
talking about corruption what is
America's role in this is it helping
Mexico or hindering know their role
between the United States and Mexico the
relationship it's a great relationship
we haven't been under such circumstances
for many years now the in this specific
moment the collaboration which in
Washington in Mexico
is at one of its highest points we work
together along a border that stretches
for thousands of kilometres one of the
longest borders in the world one of the
most dynamic borders in the world not
only economically but socially over a
million people cross that border every
day over a million dollars is traded in
between Mexico in the US Mexico and
American economy are together to North
American economy and the United States
collaborates closely indeed with all its
relevant counterparts in Mexico of
course but I think it's really an
intelligence level of course the shrugs
come in one way as well haven't you
you've got guns going the other way it's
America the drugs are trying to get to
so surely that is creating problems an
exit that's just part of it it's it's a
part of it as well as we have terrorism
or we have human trafficking of course
the border being such a big border in
his many troubles like any other border
holes what makes it easier to tackle all
of these challenges including the drug
issue is that both governments work
closely together so there's Afilias left
to go in the president's term ideally
then what change should we expect to see
when it comes to social security side
well we're still four years ahead of us
before the president's term finishes in
those four years the main objective of
course will be to reduce crime the most
persistent crimes and what we did is
look at how would you measure success or
not measure success will be lowering the
numbers lowering the numbers of
kidnappings of murderers of extortion
having strengthened police force in
especially the part of the country
what state is not as present as it
should be faster we really appreciate
your time on Sky News tonight thank you
for joining us thank you